what we are about to show you will break
your heart and give you a visual of a
reality you won't find elsewhere this is
David Dorn in his very last moments on
earth he's bleeding to death on a
sidewalk in front of a looted shop he's
a former police captain protecting a
store his name David Dorn he was 77 his
death filmed on Facebook live he was a
black man a family man a good man black
lives matter but not to looters rioters
and agitators shall we blame this on
systemic racism who shot him who knows a
stranger maybe Seth Rogan or Patton
Oswalt already bailed him out here are
words for mr. Dorrance family it was
senseless over TV's over stuff that's
replaceable and they forgetting the real
message for the protests and the
positiveness that's supposed to come out
of it and we get this negative light
that's shown on a situation that really
needed light to be brought to it fact is
fealty to the mob begets only more of
the mob redefining bloodlust as
justified leads to death and not just
mr. Dorrance but a country's to
yesterday was blackout Tuesday when
virtue signalers set their instagrams to
all black to support the protests what
an analogy for the media the media
blacks out the violence to hide their
culpability which protects incompetent
leaders and criminals in an army of
cowardly journalists their job keep the
chaos on endless repeat maybe mr.
Dorrance death can change things
maybe we can protest loudly in his name
and loudly demand action it's time
because there's no Superman coming to
save the day for us there's no one but
us
and to quote a CNN anchor who says
protest needs to be peaceful
please show me where it says that
protests are supposed to be polite and
peaceful because I can show you that
outraged citizens are the ones who have
made America what she is and led to any
major milestones be honest this is not a
tranquil time no thanks to you as cities
are ravaged he says protests don't have
to be peaceful Chris I invite you to
meet me in my neighborhood to see what
outrage created the ravaged stores the
dead-eyed looks from people trying to
salvage what's left of their lives if
only they could work in media and see
the silver lining in their ruin this is
not a tranquil time thanks for the
honesty Chris you know whan there's so
many disturbing parts to this I mean
this is obviously a a black man who
probably helped many people in black
communities throughout his life murdered
by a looter and they filmed it it wasn't
it you didn't see anybody helping him
you just saw his body bleeding out and
people people filming it yeah I mean
it's horrific
I don't think there's any thing to say
but that this is a horror show you know
it's and the idea of the social media
and even I think somebody was saying you
know hang in there you know oh gee like
old games you know like someone was
trying but to me I'm just glad that it
was removed because it's a human being
and so the people who did this Greg
should be prosecuted to the fullest
extent of the law as criminals and
having taken a good man's life I don't
think there's any way to get around that
now let me say I do have another
viewpoint on this which is that you know
we're discussing his death but we you
know we didn't discuss something like
Brianna Taylor the woman who was 26 year
old shot eight times in her bed as
police execute a no-knock warrant and
just
to her house who turned out to be the
wrong house but they killed us 26 year
old in her bed and we don't talk about
it and I think there are lots of people
this amounts them to selective moral
outrage
you know everybody picks a case and said
well I want to look at that one well why
haven't we seen more discussion not only
of Brianna Taylor remember it took two
months to have a discussion of that
Georgia jogger and if it wasn't for the
video that case might have been swept
under the rug so I think that you see a
lot of peaceful demonstrators and for
the most part peaceful demonstrators are
the story here there are looters there
are vandals there are people like those
who kill the man in st. Louis but for
most people there's just a sense of
frustration of what does it take to get
justice do you have to have the video
before someone believes you do you have
to have international protests to get
the criminal justice system to
understand that people black people are
being treated in an unjust manner I
can't I honestly can't believe you said
that after we have spent over ten days
or so talking about mr. Floyd in which
everybody is in agreement about the
horrendous death we have covered these
these in justices regularly you know
what there was a there was an elderly
couple wan that was executed at a
veteran cemetery by a black man who then
died in a forest no one dared covered
that an elderly couple visiting their
son at a cemetery so we can sit here and
you could take this story and shift it
into a tit-for-tat that's not what it's
about
this segment is not about injustice it
is about a man's death all right I
didn't see this going anywhere it's a
bad line I let me let me move on ok I
want to get other people in Dana I did
not see this story anywhere on the other
networks but online why do you think
that is do you think this isn't
important it isn't important to them
well I think that I don't know what's in
their minds but of course like whatever
you yeah whatever ends up on the front
page or whatever ends up on air is
definitely an editorial decision
somebody is making that decision and
deciding that there is other there's so
much news we could cover and they're
saying okay like this news is more
important to us and there's look we're
all drinking from a firehose there's a
lot of news out there but I also there's
tooth points I'd like to make on this
one I think the fact that there were not
police out in about in order to protect
innocent people from these looters is
rioters arsonists the people that would
commit this violence that is a horrible
thing because this man mr. Dorn he
obviously served his community as a
public servant paid his taxes he was 77
year old and then they would talk about
heartbreaking listening to his
daughter-in-law begging for justice in
this case and saying that she's
exhausted and I think we can relate to
that I also just wanted to point out one
other thing break it was devastating to
see the tears go fund me accounts for
lots of different people right so David
Doran has one and David Underwood it was
killed in Los Angeles there at about you
know fifty thousand dollars or so right
the Minneapolis freedom fund is at 20
million dollars this is driven by
celebrities and that is a bail fund
right that does not distinguish between
people who are arrested for protesting
and people that were arrested for bigger
crimes like looting and vandalism
so celebrities are bailing out them okay
fine you can do that but what does it
say as a society that these that these
men yeah are not being supported as well
and their families yeah
Jesse do you think that CNN has a
problem showing stuff like this because
they've defended anti-shah they say
nonviolent protests what's not peaceful
protests what's wrong with that so when
there's they can't show the consequences
because they're culpable yeah it's like
hiding exculpatory evidence you know
they do that in order to shape the
narrative when it doesn't fit what the
truth actually is the point is this grab
black lives matter do they matter less
when a black man takes that life or do
black lives matter more when a white
person takes that life and
Oh black all black lives matter equally
no matter who takes it yet we only see
this nationwide outrage when there's an
incident of a white person taking the
life of a black man and that's done and
you've talked about it we've talked
about it
by the Democrat media corporate power
structure and they do that to divide
they do it for profit they do it to
distract so they can put their hands in
people's pockets and keep their
positions of power because what did the
president say last week when the looting
starts the shooting starts this is a
perfect example of that and the mayor of
st. Louis she's not totally responsible
for this the looters that did this to
this guy are but she didn't protect the
community from these looters and that's
what happens when there's looting
there's death so that's on her to a
certain extent mm-hmm Lord last word to
you Lawrence I'm sure this is that any
would go ahead it is just devastating
because I feel like there has now become
this this competition for what life
matters the most
can we just like all stand up for life
like and and and just say people that
are innocent or that are killed we stand
with the families that we want to go
after the bad guys that do it you know
I'm afraid because this reminds me back
in July 7th 2016 where five cops were
shot and they with the guy that
assassinate him I had the exclusive
interview with their family and the
family told me that he was upset about a
traffic stop and he goes up there and
tries to do villa vigilante justice and
kills five cops you know what it wasn't
just that he killed five cops because
you killed someone but the five cops
that he targeted were community police
that people loved and respected in the
community that were on the task force to
bring people together and you went out
there and you shot him that's what
happened when chaos happens and I'm
afraid that America is on fire right now
I love this country
it's the greatest country in the world
but I want equal justice and I think we
should all be outraged when an innocent
American where this that
someone that wears blue or someone with
a hoodie on or someone that just from a
drive-by we should always be outraged
when one of our family members dies all
right